[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
bruce gordon was a sailor who left
aberdeen scotland in 1757
on board of a whaler called the and
forbes
the ship led by a drunken captain was
smashed between two icebergs in the
arctic
somewhere between greenland and north
cape tossed from the ship just before it
capsized
gordon was the only survivor the
capsized ship became locked in the ice
but gordon was able to carve into the
ship that was overturned
to access many of the supplies and to
create a makeshift
shelter with coal from the ship's hold
he was able to build a fire to protect
himself from the freezing weather
not long after he was attacked by a
hungry female polar bear
that incredibly he was able to kill with
a large knife strapped to a stick
that's when he spotted the small female
polar bear cub
looking for its mother gordon took pity
on her and decided to keep her
naming her nancy he fed the young cub
with whale blubber
and eventually taught her to fish for
him and defend him from other bears
gordon and nancy survived six years
living in the upside down ship
as it drifted locked in the arctic ice
eventually gordon's ice load drifted
into the northern coast of greenland
and he met a tribe of natives gordon
with the polar bear
lived with the villagers for several
months but in time
nancy began to long for bear
companionship and she disappeared into
the wild
desperate for rescue gordon paddled a
canoe out to sea
and eventually flagged down a ship from
amsterdam
and was taken aboard altogether his
odyssey on the ice lasted for seven
years and one month
so what gave bruce gordon the courage to
survive his ordeal
he had a pocket old testament his mother
had given him
which he read through several times
while marooned on the ice
friends you know the bible still
provides courage for tough times
stay with us we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends if you'd like
to call in with a question we still have
some lines open that's why we're here we
want to do our best to answer your
questions
about the word of god or living the
christian life
the number into the studio is
800-463-7297 that's 800
god says we're also streaming this
program if you want to watch and see
what's happening
you can go to the amazing facts facebook
page
or the doug batchelor facebook page and
you can see what's happening here in our
little studio
and you can text us or call us with your
bible questions
from anywhere in the world that number
again 800-463-7297 that's
800 god says and i said text i didn't
mean that
no you can't text questions but you can
call in your questions
but we do get calls from around the
world anyway hi pastor ross how you
doing hello pastor doug
good evening friends uh before we get
started with our program let's start
with prayer
dear father we thank you that we're able
to take a few moments this evening and
open up your word and study together and
we always ask your blessing upon
our time together we know the bible is
your book and so we want the holy spirit
to guide us as we
search the bible for answers in jesus
name amen amen
pastor before they we went on the air
this evening we were talking about this
amazing fact
this scotsman gordon who ended up
spending
a total of more than seven years uh six
of which
uh was on the ice in this upturned boat
companionship with a
a bear a grizzly bear no
that um they seem to build quite a
relationship where
the polar bear would even go fish and
and bring him fresh fish
yeah he grabbed people it's an amazing
story you know until
uh a few weeks ago when i found this
fact i'd never heard that before and i
thought i heard all these amazing
adventure stories
and he taught the bear to obey his
commands it answered to its name
he he taught the bear to walk in two
feet they walk along together the bear
had his paw on his shoulder of course
polar bears can get to be 14 feet tall i
mean they're
they're pretty not that much but they
get pretty big and
um and a couple of times he
almost was rescued but people saw the
bear with him and the natives they ran
off
and so it's it's quite a story but um
anyway the thing that i thought was
really interesting is his mother had
been praying for him and gave him that
little bible it was just the old
testament but uh
there through the long winters long dark
winters in the hold of that ship
he read through that bible many many
many times
and that gave him the courage right to
hang in there
and friends you know the bible still
gives you faith and courage today
and we've got a free offer we don't
often uh mention
but if you'd like a book that talks that
will encourage your faith
it's a book called who do you think you
are
and it's a book that was written
especially dealing with the subject of
faith and courage and stories of
faith that i think will inspire you we
will send it to you free
for calling and asking tonight and again
i this the book passed today i don't
think we've
offered it at least not for a very long
time on bible answers live so this is a
great free offer
book written by yourself called who do
you think you are and we'll send this to
anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747
that is the resource phone line that's
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
who do you think you are we'll be happy
to mail it to anyone
here in north america uh if you have a
bible question a phone line here to the
studio is 800-463-7297
again that's eight hundred four six
three seventy two ninety seven
all right we got our first caller this
evening we'll go to the phone lines
martha is listening in chico california
martha welcome to the program
thank you pastors for taking my call
my my question is in genesis 15
the lord had given abraham a vision
and in the vision you know he laid out
the three animals and the two birds
and in verse 12 it says and when the sun
was going down a deep sleep fell upon
him and lo
and horror of great darkness my question
is in
17 and it came to pass that when the sun
went down and it was dark
behold a smoking furnace and a burning
lamp
that passed between those pieces can you
please tell me what the smoking furnace
and the burning lamp
represent yeah i think this is talking
about the the lord
first of all when he uh he tells
abraham your descendants will be
afflicted 400 years he's talking about
the children of israel in egypt that
they'd go through this trial
he's making a covenant with abraham by
sacrifice those animals he sacrificed
for all clean animals
that they use passing between them meant
this is a covenant that god would not
ever violate and the smoking furnace and
burning lamp that's talking about like
the shekinah the glory of god passed
between them
you remember the children of israel were
led out of egypt by a pillar of fire
and so this is like the presence of the
lord
abraham um he sealed the covenant
and god ratified the covenant and uh
promising that he would deliver
abraham's people even though they went
through this terrible trial
of bondage and slavery i think also
passed today talking about the covenant
um back in bible times in the time of
abram i think one of the ways that they
made a covenant was to divide two
animals
or take an animal and divide it in two
pieces and then walk through it sounds a
little
kind of gross but they would walk
through in between the two animals
uh even with between the blood the blood
would flow out
and it was a covenant saying if i don't
if i'm not faithful to my word
this in essence is what you can do to me
i give my life
on my promise that i'm going to be
faithful and it's a remarkable thing
what it says after these animals were
divided that this burning
of pillow fire this fire came and passed
through the animals as if god
is saying i will guarantee you even on
my life that
this promise i'm going to fulfill yep so
it's a really incredible promise that
god gave to abraham
hey thank you yeah i appreciate your
question
god bless we've got uh sherry listening
in uh montana
sherry welcome to the program well hello
there
how are you i hope things are good we're
doing well thank you for calling
my question is the um
i hear i see a lot of people talking
about
this seven-year tribulation time
and i'm really confused and i even heard
somebody say that um
that with what trump has done
in israel you know acknowledged in
jerusalem and things as the capital and
stuff
but they all talked about this fabulous
seven year turbulation and i don't
understand it i just don't
um yeah well let's talk about it for a
minute
uh first of all i don't see anywhere in
the bible where it says
there will be a seven year tribulation
but because nobody knows that date that
time that hour so
right there's the the reason or the
place where they get the idea i need to
be fair and say the reason they get the
idea there's going to be a seven year
tribulation
is there are several places in the bible
where it talks about three and a half
years
you add two times three and a half you
can come up with seven
so that's one reason the other reason is
in daniel chapter 9
you've got the 490-year prophecy
and in the 490-year prophecy it talks
about the last
week or the last seven years in this
prophecy
but that's all happened already that
that prophecy points to
the sacrifice of christ and his covenant
with his people israel where he taught
in person for three and a half years
and then he taught in another three and
a half years through the apostles before
the gospel went to the gentiles with the
stoning of stephen
and so but they take that seven years
they say that's the
tribulation that'll come at the end of
time there's no reason
to separate that and do that
so we don't know how long the
tribulation will last i doubt it's seven
years because
can you imagine for a moment the seven
last plagues are falling out
seven years were the sun scorching men
with great heat
seven years of noise and plague seven
years of the oceans and fresh water
being blood
the plagues that fell on egypt came in a
matter of months not
seven years so i don't think the world
would survive
my understanding is sure things aren't
going to get better we're living in the
last days
and nothing's gonna get better but how
can i don't understand
where some people can say well
we can base things on seven years
getting worse
yeah because that that fine line nobody
knows that date that time that hour
i mean we know he's coming back but it's
the same time
we can't set dates and predict times no
no no no
no so go ahead pastor us you know i was
going to add we do have a book called
anything but secret
and it talks about the second coming of
christ and sherry you might enjoy
reading this and we'll be happy to send
it to you yes
just call and ask the number is
800-835-6747
and ask for the book it's called
anything but secret and we'll get that
in the mail and we'll send it to you if
you're outside of north america
and you'd like to read the book just go
to the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.com
and you can look it up there in the
little bar the search
section and you could read it for free
online yep now we do believe there is
going to be a tribulation there's a
great time of trouble jesus foretells
we believe he's going to save his people
through that time
so we're not worried about it because
god delivers us through tribulation
it doesn't always save us from it but
thank you appreciate your call
sherry we've got george listening in new
jersey george welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors how you doing
this week doing well
okay um well i i read a lot of
conditional immortality
literature some from your ministry and
some from other ministries
and i was surprised with some from other
ministries that
indicate that well they believe in the
destruction of the
of the unrighteous but some of them
actually believe that
satan and the beast and the false
prophet and against
the wicked angels that they will
actually be tormented forever
even though they believe in conditional
immortality for the
unsaved and i i guess that's from that
revelation 20. i forget what verse it is
10 or 11 yeah where it talks about them
being tormented uh whereas
revelation 14 doesn't say they're
tormented forever
for the unsaved it says the smoke i
think it sends forever
that's kind of word a little bit
different right you know what i'm saying
but that revelation 20
talks about that torment and and that
brings to mind can spirits actually be
annihilated because
aren't angels spirits that's what
confuses me a little bit
whereas the unrighteous have bodies yeah
well so can the
question is can spirits be annihilated
and
i would say in a word god can do
anything
and so if god can bring a spirit into
existence i know that
down in the south when mothers would
discipline their children they used to
get
they teased him they'd say i brought you
into this world i can take you out
and god he he he brought
you know lucifer he was an unfallen
angel he brought these angels in
when the angels rebelled he can
certainly take him out of existence
that's
you know the lord can do that with a
blink of an eye it's no effort for him
and so um yeah they're not god is not
going to immortalize
evil angels so that they're floating
around in the cosmos
they're burning for billions of years uh
you know
when it talks about that they'll be
consumed by the way that is revelation
chapter 20 verse 10 i think
the devil who deceived them was cast
into a lake of fire where the beast and
the false prophet are
and they'll be tormented day and night
and the phrase there
uh forever and ever i think it's from
the word eon
and that word eon it always means kind
of an unspecified period of time
basically until they're gone is what
it's saying because it says they are
consumed
talks about them being devoured and then
is it ezekiel pastor ross where it says
to jesus said to the devil
you'll be a terror and never shall you
be any more
so when god says never shall you be it
means you
cease to exist and god is not going to
give the devil immortal life he's going
to be
tormented according to what he deserves
and consumed
and i believe you i'm just looking at
that verse pastor doug um
sequel 28 i think ezekiel
oh i'll find it here
yeah anyway so you know we do have some
literature on that george and you
probably it sounds like you've been
reading our material
we've got the study guide called is the
devil in charge of hell
and there it describes what his fate is
going to be
and uh yeah it says i'll bring forth a
fire from the midst of thee and it will
devour thee and i'll bring thee
to ashes on the earth and the sight of
them that behold thou shalt be a terror
and never shalt thou be anymore
thank you we appreciate your call i'm
just looking we do have a study guide
that goes along with that it's called
did god create a devil
and we'll be able to send that out to
anyone who rules and asks
again the number for that is just simply
call 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the study
guide did god create a devil and all the
bible verses
are there next quarter that we have is
chris listening from georgia chris
welcome to the program
chris yeah
yeah i've been trying guys last time i
didn't get it but thank goodness
now i got you guys my question is found
in proverbs uh 11
through 12 it says my son despises
the chastening of the lord and in the
correction i'm like
is this gotta lose with temptation oh i
mean how is the lord correct his
kids or chase to them that's my question
good question uh you know god does
chasing those he loves and uh he doesn't
it can be several things one it could be
uh circumstances that bring us into
trials
it can be a physical suffering
it can be that um you know we we lose
our peace and joy because we've taken
our eyes off the lord
and to go through i mean god has got a
thousand ways of kind of disciplining
his children
often he'll uh he knows exactly where
you need it
when isaiah confessed his sin to the
lord he said i am a man of unclean lips
and i dwell in the midst of a people of
unclean lips
so god took a coal and put it on his
lips
i mean it didn't burn him but it was his
way of saying i'll purge your lips
and uh so um yeah
the lord you know i've just seen in my
own life
uh the lord has disciplined me a lot of
ways that uh
before i was a christian i was a thief
and i'd steal something and people would
steal it from me
and it was like i was getting it's not
that i believe in karma but you know god
was rewarding me
according to what i deserved the bible
says with what measure you meet it'll be
measured to you
we do bad to other people bad often
comes back
if you're merciful god is merciful with
you and so
there's a broad spectrum of ways that
god might discipline his
people to try and get their attention
you can see examples of this in the way
he dealt with israel too
many times you'd lead them into
difficult situations so they'd recognize
their need of god
it could be a drought it could be an
alien army it could be a plague
several things happen all right well
thanks for your call our next caller
that we have is
phil listening in new york phil welcome
to the program thanks
how you guys doing tonight good glad to
be able to talk about the bible
oh good here yeah my question is
do you think there is a connection
between the
the reestablishment of national israel
and the second advent of jesus and if so
what is that connection good question
you know many people read the prophecy
and pastor ross might find this for us i
think it's
it's luke 17 or 21 and until the time of
the gentiles be fulfilled
jerusalem will be trodden down by the
gentiles until the time of the gentiles
be fulfilled
and some have looked at that and said
well when
you know jerusalem was sort of occupied
by either the crusaders
or the muslims for hundreds of years
and finally after world war ii they were
able to get their property back and many
have seen that as a historic landmark
some people have looked at this last
year pastor ross and i were in israel
the on the 70th anniversary of their
independence
and uh they had just moved the capital
to jerusalem and i'll tell you there's a
lot of
a lot of people were thinking that that
was you know a real landmark decision
but i don't see anywhere in the bible
where we can look at what's happened
with israel to set a date
for the second coming do i think we're
living in the last days yes
absolutely i think that the
what's happened to israel in my mind
is a reminder of the validity
of the bible because there's no nation
in the world that comes even close to
the phenomenon of the jews
who have been dispossessed from their
homeland
three times in the days of jacob they
had to leave but they came back
and after the exodus in the time of the
babylonians they were carried away but
they came back
and the romans conquered them and they
were dispersed and then 1900 years later
they came back and they've remained a
unique people
every other nation when they're
conquered and they are dispersed
they intermarry they evaporate they are
deluded they lose their identity
as a distinct people the jewish nation
has remained distinct
and i think it's because the scriptures
have held them together
it's so do i think it's prophetic i
think it's remarkable evidence
that god has been watching over the
descendants of abraham
i don't think we can use it as a um a
benchmark to set a time for christ
coming
the verse you're referring to pastor
doug luke chapter 21 verse 24
speaks of the time of the gentiles be
for being fulfilled right yeah
well we thank you very much and we do
have a book on spiritual israel we'll be
happy to send you a free copy
carl the number to call for that is 800
675 and again the just asked for the
book called spiritual israel we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks uh we'll go to uh carol
listening in texas carol welcome to the
program
hello hi thank you for calling
hi pastor dan pastor so good to speak to
you thank you for your ministry
it's a privilege okay so
um i am calling on behalf of my son we
were having this discussion about
matthew 12 40. and he read somewhere
um that there's some contradiction
between
the account in luke 23 55 and 56
and mark 16 as for when the woman
went to another piece of his body and
also
um the other part of that is that um
something about leviticus um it being a
seven days a two sabbath the the weekly
sabbath and the seventh
year sabbath as well could you explain
that please all right well let's start
with the first question
and the first question springs from a
common misunderstanding
when people read in matthew chapter 12
verse 40
for as jonah was three days and three
nights in the belly of the great fish
so the son of man will be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth
and they say well if jesus died on
friday
how could he be three days and three
nights well maybe he was
part of three days in the grave but not
three nights
you know this is not talking about the
grave at all this is the common mistake
when
it says the sound of man will be in the
heart of the earth everyone
automatically assumes that means the
tomb
but where else in the bible is the heart
of the earth called the tomb
there is no verse when we pray the
lord's prayer thy will be done in earth
we don't mean in the tomb so what jesus
is saying here as jonah was in the belly
of the fish
the son of man will be three days and
three nights in the clutches of the
world
see jesus began suffering for our sins
on thursday night
he even told the disciples now is the
hour in other words you can start your
stopwatch he said now is the hour
and he began to suffer for our sins
thursday night
friday night saturday night he suffered
both death and burial
rising sunday morning three days and
three nights he was suffering the
penalty for the sins of the world
which is suffering and death not just
the death
and that started thursday night
following the last supper when he sealed
the covenant
and he prayed not my will thy will be
done so people look at that and they
think we need to move the time for the
resurrection or the crucifixion we don't
have to move anything
last supper thursday night christ began
to suffer for the sins of the world
he was betrayed he told the disciples
wake up now is the hour
thursday night friday morning he was
tried beaten whipped
crucified friday afternoon he died
he was buried he rose sunday morning for
three days and three nights
that's what that verse is talking about
heart of the earth does not mean the
tomb it means the clutches of the lost
world he was suffering in the hands of
the devil now does that make
sense carol yes boston
you know i've got a book i'd like to
send you that answers and i think it
helps answer your other question
it's called the sign of jonah we'll send
that to you for free
and again if you'd like to receive that
the number to call is 883
and i just asked for the book called the
sign of jonah we'll be happy to put in
the mail and send it out to
anyone in north america if you're
outside of the country and i know we
have people listening past the doug on
facebook and
in different countries because we get
calls from people all over even from
africa and other places
you can read the book by just going to
the amazing facts website and you can go
to our free library and you can click on
there
the sign of jonah and you can read the
book it doesn't take
too long to read but it's got a lot of
great information and pastor doug we're
coming up on our break
the program's not over we're just taking
a short break and we'll be back but
maybe this is a good time to tell our
listeners about an exciting
upcoming event that's going to be taking
place next month
absolutely friends i tell you there has
been no time better than now
to tell people what the purpose of life
is folks everywhere
when they look at what's going on in the
world with the
pandemic with people being polarized
politically with the social unrest with
the economic instability
uh folks are really worried about the
future i mean when you have a run on
toilet paper
folks get worried what is something
serious actually happens and the markets
are stripped from food
and so folks are wondering are we
entering the last days what does
prophecy have to say
we are going to do a special program
that will be broadcast from right here
in sacramento it's around the sacramento
area
to the world via the internet and it's
called revelation
now everybody if you're hearing my voice
you can participate in this program
it'll be on amazing facts television
three abn
the three angels broadcasting network
it'll be on the facebook
you know we're gonna have zoom meetings
you can have zoom home groups it'll
broadcast on youtube it'll be on
facebook
i mentioned that didn't i and if you
want to know more about how you can set
up your group
go to revelationnow.com get involved in
this upcoming program october 23
to november 14. now we're coming back
with questions so don't go far
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back to
saline friends we are
in the studio bible answers live you
want to join us online just go to the
amazing facts facebook page or the doug
batchelor facebook page
and we see some of you standing by jerry
gabriel roger
sammy jamie we're going to try and get
your questions there are still a couple
lines open
and so join us for this second half
we're going to do our best to answer any
bible question
we don't claim to know all the answers
but we've got our bibles here and we
will search together
i'm doug batchelor my name is john ross
and we've got jamie listening from
connecticut jamie welcome to the program
thank you for having me and i really
appreciate your ministry
i do have a question regarding first
timothy
chapter four one
through verses one through
five all right can i read that for folks
sure
now the spirit speaks expressly saying
in the latter times
some will depart from the faith giving
heed to the deceiving spirits and
doctrines of devils
speaking lies in hypocrisy having their
own conscience seared with a hot iron
forbidding to marry and commanding to
abstain from
foods which god has created to be
received with thanksgiving
by those who believe and know the truth
for every creature of god is good and
nothing to be refused if it's received
with thanksgiving
for it's sanctified by the word of god
in prayer
so are you wondering does that mean that
every creature of god is good to eat
yes that's what the discussion was with
a few other people
and i know to cross-reference
uh scripture with scripture
you know but the thing is is i still had
trouble
um trying to convey what these verses
mean
yeah i can see where a lot of people get
kind of
stuck on this and let me help you with
what some of the key words are here
first of all the background in the days
of paul there's a big argument you can
find it in several of paul's writings
it's in uh second corinthians it's in
romans 14
where jewish converts to christianity
these were jews who had become
christians
were telling the gentile christians
you cannot eat the foods meaning
even the clean meats that were offered
to uh gods they used to butcher the
animals and they always offered the goat
or the chicken whatever it was
to some roman or greek god before they
killed it and the jesus said now you're
you're participating in idolatry if you
eat that
and paul said look you didn't offer it
to a god every creature of god is good
nothing to be refused
now he's talking about which creatures
he said it's okay for us to eat
creatures
that are created uh in that way
but you read earlier in the verse he
says this uh
this evil power will forbid the mary and
command people to abstain from foods now
what foods
foods which god created to be received
with thanksgiving
by those who know and believe the truth
that means the word of god
and it says that these creatures are
sanctified by the word of god what
creatures are sanctified by the word of
god
you can read in leviticus it says some
are clean
and so paul is not saying you think
about it here
is paul saying that anything that crawls
should be food for humans now our bodies
are the temple of the holy spirit
clearly adam was a vegetarian his god's
original plan for man was not to kill
anything
in heaven there'll be no more death and
you ask any doctor
is it unhealthy for a christian to eat
certain foods are there some meats
that have a lot more cholesterol than
others of course we know that
and don't be deceived god is not mocked
people will reap what they sow
if you keep reaping or keep sowing
cholesterol you'll reap a heart attack
you can't mock god
no parent would take the excuse if their
kids were on the way to school and they
said i'll make my own breakfast this
morning
and they go to the freezer and they pull
out the neapolitan ice cream
and they start to make a big old banana
split for breakfast and smother it with
caramel and chocolate syrup
and you say to your kids what in the
world are you doing and they say don't
worry mom and dad i'm gonna pray over it
before i eat it
and it will be sanctified you would say
that's ludicrous
uh so people cannot say you can eat
whatever you want
just pray over it that's not what god is
saying here
does that make sense that makes a lot of
sense to me and then i have one more
question related to this sure regarding
the references that you just gave me
where
do i find a good cross-referencing book
for well if you want to find out what
creatures are good i think you can look
where
leviticus 18 11 you'll have
the animals that are clean and unclean
keep in mind everybody's related to noah
god made a distinction between the clean
and the unclean animals
for noah and his family it's not a
jewish law
and it was considered an abomination to
bring any unclean animal into the temple
and our bodies are the temple of the
holy spirit
so you're looking for a good concordance
probably the the word that's all the
cross references that you can look
in in different topics and there's some
free concordances that's available
online the young's concordance is good
uh the strongs also is a concordance
that can be used so there's some there's
some good resource out there that you
can
you can access well thank you for your
call jamie we've got uh
sammy listening from north carolina
sammy welcome to the program
hello bastard hello pastor ross i have a
question regarding
slavery like in the bible why does the
bible
don't have a clear statement to the
slavery or jesus
like he during his life on earth he
didn't make a clear statement
well i think he did i think he did i
think that when jesus said do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you
that i think is a pretty strong
statement i mean i wouldn't want to be a
slave
why would i want to make someone else a
slave and jesus said that we're to love
our neighbor as we love ourselves
you know if you love somebody you're not
going to put them in bondage
now did god make provisions for slaves
in the bible
he did to protect them so in the bible
you find that
slavery was ubiquitous all over
the world they had slaves and many of
them were mistreated
and so god said in the sabbath
commandment you're supposed to let
everybody rest including your slave
he said that there were laws that were
to protect slaves
so uh it wasn't that god was endorsing
it
god does not endorse divorce
jesus said because of the hardness of
your hearts god made a provision for
divorce
wasn't his will god does not endorse
polygamy but god had laws to protect
wives if there were multiple wives in a
marriage because everyone was doing it
and he wanted to protect them so he made
laws
he wasn't endorsing it god often made
laws to
um accommodate uh you know the
what was happening in the society not
because he was condoning it
does that help sammy answer your
question yeah a little bit
yeah a little bit thank you yeah god is
love and he
he's god does uh doesn't endorse or
support slavery he thinks that uh
jesus came he said you'll know the truth
and the truth will make you free
he wants us to be free and he wants us
to free each other
you know we do have an interesting book
there pastor doug in new testament it's
not very
red very often yeah philemon or philemon
where paul is writing uh to someone who
apparently at some point had a slave but
he was converted
and paul writes and says you know
receive him as a brother
not as a slave and that's uh that's
really one verse 16. there's only one
chapter in the book
so it is a good point good point that's
a good good argument
against slavery right there we've got
roger listening in colorado roger
welcome to the program
thank you for having me pastors my
question is very simple and i've been
i'm being challenged by this all the
time genesis
1 verses 1 and 2.
there is a gap
and i could not really find the gap but
i read it over and over and i could see
where people are calling it a gap
you see that where you put the gap
between when he made the heaven and the
earth
and then when he actually started to
form the earth
yeah i i think that when you read
genesis keep in mind the verses are not
there so first let's get that out of the
way there were no verses in the original
those were added 300 years after christ
what you're reading is in the first
words of the bible is a sweeping
headline
where moses is basically saying i'm
going to provide
an inspired account for the origin of
life on earth
in the beginning god is the author he
created everything above
everything below so that's the headline
now in the jewish way of thinking
they often give the headline then they
back up and give the details
you'll notice even in genesis it
explains
how god made the earth in six days but
then it backs up and it tells more about
how god made woman
gives more detail but gives the
headlines first you see actually that
all through genesis where it'll give a
big headline then it'll back up and give
the details
but there's no million-year billion-year
100-year gap
between you know when god makes the
heavens and the earth
and then thousands of years go by before
he actually starts creating the earth
i think pastor just add to that this
idea of there being some kind of a gap
or the six days of creation being long
periods of time
was really an attempt to try and
harmonize
some of the teachings of evolution with
some of the teachings that you find in
the bible and people were trying to
read things into the scriptures that's
just not there to try and justify a
belief
in evolution over long periods of time
yeah one reason we know that these times
are literal
is because god makes the vegetation on
the third day
but he doesn't make the sun moon and
stars until the fourth day so
if those days are not literal days and
how does the vegetation survive
for you know hundreds or thousands of
years with no sunlight
so if these were days that were
contiguous
24-hour periods everything in the
language is making it say evening and
morning first day second day third day
and it's no problem for god he can he
can build these things instantly
thank you appreciate that roger thank
you very much you just cleared a lot of
things up for me thank you praise god
thanks for calling
next quarter that we have is uh andre
listening from uh
new york andre welcome to the program hi
are you doing uh hello can you explain
to me about the rapture
because so many things are going on now
and when you see these signs and folk
walk
a little bit i really don't know much
but uh
you know when you you know according to
matthew 24
7 mark 13 yes equal 38
you know that we're living in the times
of now okay sorry bye
no i'm glad you called thank you for
your question andrew now the word
rapture
and pastor and i ross and i we believe
the bible teaches that believers will be
caught up to meet the lord in the air
you find that in 1 thessalonians chapter
it says the lord himself will descend
from heaven with a shout with the voice
of the archangel the trump of god and
the dead in christ will rise
and we who are alive and remain will be
caught up
that's what the word rapture means to be
caught up well we don't believe
is a couple of things one some people
believe the rapture is a secret
that folks are all going to be walking
around the street and boof all the
christians are going to disappear
the bible says the day of the lord will
come as a thief in the night that
doesn't mean
that people won't know when it happens
because you read the rest of that verse
and this is second peter chapter 3
the day of the lord will come as a thief
in the night in which the heavens and
the earth will pass away
with a great noise the elements will
melt
with fervent heat the earth and the
works the aaron will be burned up so if
everything's burned up and it's passed
away with a great noise
the rapture is not a secret it says the
wicked are destroyed by the brightness
of his
coming and i think that's in 2nd
thessalonians if i'm not mistaken
so we do believe it we don't believe
it's secret
and we think the tribulation happens
before the rapture
so there is going to be a great
tribulation a lot of good christians out
there
believe the tribulation happens after
the rapture
and some believe it happens in the
middle of the rapture some believe it
happens
before the rapture we believe that
christ said
he that endures to the end will be saved
that we're going to be here and there's
something to endure
christ said you'll be hated by all
nations for my name's sake
and god tends to save his people through
trials
not from them and so the rapture we
believe takes place
following a very serious time of trouble
in the world
we do have a study guide it's called the
ultimate deliverance and it talks about
the second coming of christ
and signs of the second coming as well
as events leading up to that
we'll be happy to send the study guide
out to anyone in north america just call
and ask it's called the ultimate
deliverance it's part of the amazing
facts study guide
series and the number call is
800-835-6747
and again ask the study guide it's
called the ultimate deliverance that's
800-835-6747
next quarter that we have is gabriel
listening from
albuquerque new mexico gabriel welcome
to the program
good evening pastor doug and uh pastor
ross
i'm god bless you all at the amazing
facts organization thank you
and your first question yes it's in
regards to luke 8
chapter or chapter 8 and mark chapter 6
the resurrection of jairus daughter my
question is
well why did it why is it seemingly um
or why did it seem that jesus
wanted to not to be known that this
miracle was performed you know several
times when jesus healed somebody
he said you know go and don't say
anything about this
because he knew that the opposition to
his work
of teaching and preaching was going to
be exacerbated
by his sharing by people seeing the
miracles some miracles were so
uh remarkable that you know he'd heal
these blind people he said don't tell
anybody they'd go everywhere and tell
everybody
now there was a couple times jesus did a
miracle and he said go tell people
when he was in the country of decopolis
on the other side of the sea of galilee
there was a lot of gentiles there
he wasn't going to get the same
opposition that he would get in the land
of judea
so he healed this demoniac and he said
go tell your friends what god has done
for you and they and he did
but when he'd do something he'd be a
little closer to jerusalem
he'd say look don't say anything because
he knew the priests and the religious
leaders were very jealous and very
opposed
to his popularity and the more miracles
he did
the more angry they became and so he
often would do a miracle and say
you know don't say anything you know
another thing passed today is some of
the miracles involved
a declaration by the priest that the
person was healed
for example the man was healed of
leprosy he needed to have the priest
declared that he was healed so he could
go back to his home with his family
knowing the prejudice that the priests
would have towards the work of jesus
if this man came in and said oh jesus
healed me they probably wouldn't have
given a
fair report as to whether or not he's
actually healed so jesus said go
straight to the priest first get the
declaration
don't tell anyone however as you get
near the end of christ's ministry he
doesn't say that especially when it
comes to the healing of lazarus yeah
it's a very public miracle of course
they were
numbered and uh yeah you didn't
but can you imagine today we've probably
all seen it before where somebody
suddenly
they become the focus of some great
notoriety
there's they've done some heroic thing
they've done some
very bad thing and they walk out their
front door and there's all these media
trucks and satellites and reporters and
can you imagine today if jesus like
raised the dead some documented meta
they'd have every reporter with a an
agent on his front lawn he couldn't go
anywhere he can't do anything
and it was bad it was like that back
then he was performing miracles and just
everybody wanted to just follow him from
place to place
he had to send the crowds away and get
in a boat just to continue doing the
ministry among his friends
so if he kept aggravating his enemies he
knew they would really
hinder his work all right well thanks
for your call gabriel we've got uh tony
listening in bakersfield california tony
welcome to the program
well thank you for having me yeah and
your question so
then my question is um it's proverbs 8
22 and i know we're not going to get all
the way through 30
but uh my question is who's speaking
there and maybe what are they who they
maybe who are they speaking of or
themselves
yeah i just uh i yeah i heard an
interpretation and
that this sauna didn't write to me and i
just wanted to clarify it
the whole chapter is solomon is talking
in
poetic form about wisdom he's talking
about
my fruit is better than gold and that's
verse 19. he's talking about wisdom you
go to the first verses in chapter eight
it's pretty clear there
he says does wisdom cry out and
understanding lift up her voice
she wisdom takes her stand on the top of
the high hill
and the whole passage is talking about
the value
of wisdom so when you get into verse 22
the lord possessed me at the beginning
of his way before his works of old
god wisdom has always been with god and
so he means you know
back in the remote recesses of eternity
wisdom has always been there with god
and you know that's why james says if
any man lacks wisdom let him ask of god
and when you talk about the
characteristics of the spirit
that you find in isaiah 11 verse 2 it
identifies
wisdom so some people think that this is
talking about the birth or creation of
jesus
but it's not it's talking about what the
the attributes
and the beauties of wisdom
thank you uh no just the interpretation
that my nephew was getting
um he was being told um that it's
that he was a an angel that people are
angels before the beginning of
um that they're the angels before
they're humans and that they were there
talking with god and then they became
human and it just was
i i've been studying and i just yeah i
know a particular church that teaches
that and yeah that's pretty far-fetched
from what it's really saying there
but uh i appreciate that does that make
sense the answer
it i i thought it was wisdom and i i was
kind of going with wisdom and i just
yeah it does help me and i just want to
try to help him out yeah thank you
yeah if you we read in its context it's
solomon is talking about wisdom he the
whole book of proverbs is called
sometimes what the books of wisdom
and uh yeah chapter eight is concentrate
all right we've got uh jerry listening
in texas jerry welcome to the program
hey pastor ross bastard thanks for
taking my call just a couple of
quick things before my question i love
that polar bear story tonight
and uh you also talk past ross about a
book of faith and you also have a book
called beyond the grave
uh and for next time i want you guys to
study
second samuel 28 i have a few questions
next week for you on that
all right my question today is the
simple question pastor ross
uh was there a sabbath
before god created the sabbath you know
6 000 years ago
you know and we know that there will be
a sabbath throughout eternity
but was there a sabbath before okay good
question
pastor ross you want to answer that well
you know as far as the earth goes the
bible says god created the earth in six
days and then he rested on the seventh
day and he sanctified the seventh day
and he set it apart and of course the
earth
made new uh it they'll still be a
sabbath as you read from the new heavens
the new earth
was there though a time where the angels
gathered together in heaven prior to the
creation of the earth to worship god
i don't think we have any reason to
doubt that there was some particular
time
but as far as earth goes uh the sabbath
is closely connected to
creation and that's the origin for us to
think back
god is the creator he's the and you find
that of course in genesis chapter two
so yeah i think that uh that's a good
answer we
we have a book on that we could talk
about um
the almost forgotten day yes that's
right or the last day of history
and that's one of our study guides yes
it's called the last day of history and
jerry you might have seen this maybe you
haven't if you haven't we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
it's just called the last day of history
it's one of our
amazing facts study guides and just call
and ask for that
and we'll get that to you uh next
quarter that we have is
uh robert listening from washington
robert welcome to the program
hey you squeezed me in
and we didn't want to leave you out and
your question okay
yeah i was wondering about uh i
understand
i've heard before about there's that
there's just one true church
and this one true church
they can only baptize that they're only
allowed to baptize
and because they've got the priesthood
authority
and supposedly that no one else is saved
unless they do the baptizing thing can
you explain that
a little bit in two or three minutes
well yeah we'll do our best
um first of all i don't agree with that
i know there's some churches that teach
that you know it's always
it's always very convenient for every
denomination to say
only members of our church will be saved
and so if you want to be saved you got
to join our church kind of puts pressure
on people
not to go somewhere else and just buy
their product
one of the things that attracted me to
the church that i'm now part of
is they did not say we're the only ones
that are being saved they recognize that
they'll be saved christians in many
other churches
and there's people who are baptized
maybe they're baptized incorrectly
and they might not be baptized you know
exactly as the bible says or
it may have been sprinkled and that's
not you know it's not the only criteria
i think there's going to be a lot of
people in heaven that maybe did not
understand some things
in acts chapter 30 i think it's verse
know it's acts 17 30
god winks at their ignorance so
um i do believe the bible says one lord
one faith one baptism there is one
true lord there is one true faith and
there's one correct way to baptize
and the lord wants us to be a united
people
but and baptism should be done by those
who are
authorized by the church that so
candidates for baptism can be
you know evaluated that they are
genuinely converted
john the baptist said bring forth fruits
meet for repentance and
i think there was some screening of
those he baptized
so you know it's appropriate to have the
pastors or some
authorized people do the baptizing
but the idea that only
one sure only those who are baptized in
a particular denomination by a
particular priesthood
are going to be saved i don't think it's
taught in the bible you know pasadena we
do have a book it's called baptism
is it really necessary and it deals with
the subject of baptism what does the
bible say about it
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks again that number is
just
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
baptism is it really necessary and we'll
go ahead and get that in the mail
if you're outside of north america as we
mentioned before you can read it for
free
online by just going to the amazing
facts website amazingfacts.org.com
you know pastor like i see we do have
some folks who are waiting for us to
take their call but we probably wouldn't
do justice to take the call we're
looking at the clock and we have less
than a minute and a half before we get
rushed off the air but
we mentioned at the break this upcoming
program for folks wanting to study the
bible further
and it's if you just join us halfway
through the program
a special series uh a total of 20
presentations
dealing with a number of important bible
truths
it's called revelation now everything is
about to change and that is
october the 23rd when it begins yes
october 23
this year until november 14 and if
you've got
your phone or your computer next to you
remember or even log on right now
revelation now and if you'd like to
participate it will just send you a
little reminder
when the program begins some people say
oh that sounds great i want to be part
of it and they forget
we'll send you a little text a little
reminder so you can participate bring
your friends along
if you go through this program i
guarantee it'll strengthen your faith
and it'll bring a lot of people to jesus
and the whole idea is to prepare us for
the second coming
we'll be providing a lot of free
materials to study the bible
to have a closer walk with the lord and
know that you're ready
for the days that are ahead of us right
now we are living in interesting times
listening friends we'll look forward to
studying god's word with you next week
i hope you're blessed and you'll help
keep amazing facts on the air
just click amazingfacts.org
and you know what to do god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets political tensions
are at an
all-time high does the bible have
anything to say about the
times in which we are living hi friends
this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering if the world's
about to implode
some are fearful that global events
point to a coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy
more truth-filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library at aftv.org
at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study
of god's word sign up today for this
free bible study course by calling
1-844-215-7000 that's 1-844-215-7000
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at af afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org